vrai qu'on revienne à vous êtes
sénatrice vous êtes sénatrice depuis 11
ans maintenant et il ya une actualité en
ce moment au sénat pour le meilleur ou
pour le pire c'est la question du voile
or mairie d'actualité au sénat son
actualité dans tous les médias j'ai
enfin moi j'ai l'impression qu'on en
sortira jamais de ce débat je suis je
suis né en 88 et en 89 telle affaire de
creil
aujourd'hui en 2019 et j'ai l'impression
qu'on est toujours pas sorti de ce débat
non ça vous étonne vous continuez en par
ailleurs 2019 ou pas oui moi ça mais moi
ça m'étonne au 21ème siècle pour se
poser des questions de cette façon là
d'abord moi je suis pour moi je suis
parti ce n'est pas par principe vous
savez moi je quelqu'un qui vous reprenez
la la liberté de chacun d'eux fut de
vivre de s'habiller et des d'expekt
faire ce qu'il veut voilà ça s'appelle
la liberté ça s'appelle de respecter
l'autre dans sa liberté mais de me
respecter aussi dans la mienne et ils le
port je pas force je suis pas une
défenseuse du port du voile pas ma
conception mais pour autant au nom de
quoi
maintenant il va falloir qu'on définisse
entre scott en france en dix ans mais
cette maman elle peut pas les amener
accompagner son enfant en sortie
scolaire
alors je suis le mans porte foulard au
nom de quoi vous siéger au sein de la
commission culture et éducation au sénat
qui à partir d'hier a commencé à
examiner ce matin soit un magma examiner
voilà le projet de loi la proposition de
loi pardon qui a été déposée et qui vise
à interdire le voile pour les mamans qui
accompagnent les sorties scolaires
tout le monde a l'air divisé au sénat
sur ces questions là au sein même des
groupes politiques tout le monde n'est
pas d'accord j'ai vu ça j'ai vu ça vous
avez bien raison de dire ça parce que
vous soyez à gauche quand vous soyez à
droite il ya une division au sein des
mois j'ai vu mdd du parti communiste
des des choses qui était dit j'ai été
assez surprise jeu quand je pars un peu
surprise
mais bon c'est comme ça ç'a permis
peut-être déjà permet aussi clarifier
les positions designs offre ses dires à
géométrie variable voyez là ce qu'on dit
quand on est à l'extérieur il ya ce
qu'on dit quand on est à l'intérieur
mais sur cette question là moi je veux
je veux je veux je suis triste je suis
triste parce que je trouve que on apaise
pas finalement les choses ont contraire
on les les aliments dont léon les excite
et encore une fois une maman qui quelque
effet une maman est-ce que les deux
mamans qui accompagnent des enfants pas
son enfant parce qu'il faut arrêter de
dire qu'elle accompagne son enfant non
elle accompagne les enfants à la cabane
la classe moi je suis une maman m'est
arrivé d'aller en sortie
scolaire ne sorte accompagné mon fils je
vais pas souvent mais je lui fais pas ce
que je voulais pas que mon fils se
sentent seulement parce que sa maman
était c'est n'apprécie pas toujours à la
maison qu'elle partage pas ces moments
et pour moi c'est des moments aussi
important de la vie laisse important des
moments importants de la vie d'une maman
ou un papa d'accompagner à ces sorties
scolaires son enfant et donc ses enfants
mais moi quand je suis arrivé quand j'ai
m'est arrivé de le faire d'abord il ya
un coupon quand vous avez des enfants où
on vous dit est ce que vous autorisez
votre enfant sortir pour aller au cinéma
pour aller au musée avec la place ça
veut dire qu'on considère bien qu'on
n'est plus dans le cadre vraiment
scolaire parce que moi l'enseignant me
demande pas mon autorisation pour faire
faire des maths du français à mon enfant
je comprends dit non je comprends
l'argument voilà là on me demande
l'autorisation de pouvoir mener mon
enfant sait bien que c'est pas
obligatoire dans la cadre de la
scolarité
il ya un débat mais c'est justement là
truc se pose le débat à la salle cadre
juridique donc moi quand j'ai amené mon
envie quand j'ai accompagné la classe je
n'ai en aucun moment je n'ai participé à
l'aspect pédagogique de sa sortie je
n'ai fait que faire en sorte que
l'enfant bay il traverse bien au passage
piéton que des voitures ne viennent pas
perturber le passage que personne ne
vienne d'extérieur se mettre au milieu
des enfants
je me suis occupé de la sécurité des
enfants et ils m'ont rôle et c'est l
enseignante café son rôle d'enseignante
dans la pédagogie de l'enfant donc en
quelques mots qu à quel moment la maman
qui a parce qu'elle a un foulard elle va
perturber finalement la pédagogie de
l'enfant c'est ça qui est passé quand
j'en joue la perversité dans cette
affaire c'est que ces deux importants et
vézien sincèrement ce qui va se passer
n'aura plus de sorties scolaires parce
que quand on dit ah mais les français
sont d'accord à 60%
mais est ce qu'on dit aux français est
ce qu'on dit aux mamans qui ne peuvent
pas prendre les rtt
est ce qu'on dit aux mamans qui ne
peuvent pas tout simplement parce
qu'elles n'ont pas la possibilité
première tétée pascal noël 13 sont
obligés d'aller travailler parce
qu'elles n'ont pas elle se remarie n'ont
pas la possibilité d'accompagner leurs
enfants
est-ce que vous acceptez que vos enfants
dans ce cas-là n'aillent plus en sorties
extrascolaires
est ce que c'est ça la question qu'il
faut poser faut poser les vraies
questions
et puis comme ça la grève des cantines
scolaires moi j'ai vu des mamans demandé
à la maman voilée de venir
si elle pouvait récupérer l'enfant
pendant la période de cantine scolaire
parce qu'elle est là le travail et et
qu'elle ne pouvait pas garder leurs
enfants parce qu'il n'y a pas forcément
les papis et les mamies et parce que
quand on l'agly à des grèves mais on est
bien content d'avoir la mine à maman du
petit garçon du petit corps de la petite
copine qui gardent l'enfant et l'on se
pose pas de questions si elle porte le
foulard du coup ya une forme
d'hypocrisie selon vous pousse à des
ballerines et c'est quoi je pense quand
je pense qu'on pose pas bien les
questions je pense que quand on veut on
n'a pas bien posé la question aux
français parce que si on dit aux
français
est ce que finalement vous préfériez
qu'il n'y ait plus de sorties tant pis
plutôt que d'avoir une maman qui parce
qu'elle a une foule la raccompagne je
connaissais pas le sont pas dit
cependant pas des sorcières c'est des
mamans et qu'ils s'occupent de leurs
enfants souvent qu'ils sont élitistes
d'ailleurs je regarde un peu s'il ya un
débat dans le chatt actuellement
justement sur ce sujet là il ya et il y
à bakar en fait qui pose la question de
savoir est ce que c'est vraiment un acte
libres de porter le voile c'est oui oui
c'est un acte de liberté
c'est un acte de liberté bon je
considère qu au nom de quoi alors
pourquoi je sais pas moi porter des
lunettes vous pouvez mettre des
lentilles pourquoi vous n'êtes pas
opérer pour vous mettez pas des lanciers
portée du lot cette scène acte libre un
moment faut arrêter
non mais je crois qu'ils sont
médicalement autre chose que voulait de
l'armée mais je le dire c'est que oui
mais c'est même si un dispositif vous
avez raison médicale j'aurais dû prendre
il a quand même non mais
mais je vis un moment au nom de quoi
d'abord défi qu'il le faut arrêter de
croire qu'elles le font parce qu'elles
sont opprimés obligé c'est pas vraiment
je vois des mamans qui ont mon âge qui
ont des filles qui ont 18 ans 20 ans 25
ans qui porte le foulard et portant les
mamans je peux vous dire qu'elles ne
sont pas du tout là dedans
donc elles n'ont pas été éduqués à ça et
comment vous expliquez que dans une même
famille vous avez celle qui va avoir le
soûlard vous avez une autre qui va pas
qui va être fashion victim voilà ils
n'ont mais le jeu donc on est sous les
eaux plus les gens qui sont pas d'accord
avec vous vous opposeront
le communautarisme le fait qu'il ya des
règles religieuses qui s'impose est que
choisir de ceux de respecter une règle
religieuse n'est pas faire acte de
liberté que la liberté c'est
l'émancipation par rapport aux règles
religieuses
oui c'est les mêmes et c'est les même
pour certains notamment pour la droite
c'est les mêmes qui étaient contre le
mariage pour tous qui ont manifesté pour
dire que parce qu'ils aient les mêmes
qui vont à l'église
et c'est les mêmes qui sont attendez moi
j'en ai aussi entendre tout ça mais moi
on n'arrête pas de me parler de demain
je mens je suis je suis une forte
troisièmement profondément laïque vous
me trouverez nulle part dans la dessus
donc j'ai pas de problème avec ça
mais justement parce que j'ai pas de
problème mais d'ailleurs c'est c'est
souvent d'ailleurs ce oui bon je veux
dire quand je vois que quand on va dans
les et moi j'ai pas il m'arrive de faire
je fais la procession parce que ça
devait à marseille on dénie sur les jeux
notamment saint pierre parce que c'est
une tradition marseillaise pour les
pêcheurs et mais pour que la mère
abondent et protège les pêcheurs et les
passants donc apporte beaucoup de
poissons et protège les pêcheurs donc
quand je fais ça je ne sens pas je le
fais je le fais aussi dans une tradition
plus une tradition que dans une aspects
religieux pourtant il ya depuis le curé
qui est là et ça mais c'est un dément je
me détache de tout ça il ya le curé je
considère je respecte pourquoi ça serait
hélas quand je vois par contre tous les
élus et du front national et de droite
et qui se prennent vite et prennent
aussi et qui font la prière et qui se
met à genoux et ge a pas de souci en
fait mon job ça ne pose aucun problème à
presser leurs droits c'est leur liberté
et pourquoi enlever pourquoi dans ce cas
là nous allons par contre la femme qui
elle parce qu'elles portent un foulard
finalement mais qui c'est qui qui est
finalement pas libre car c'est
intéressant ce qu'on fait vous êtes en
train de revenir sur un clivage droite
gauche alors que tout à l'heure on était
d'accord vous et moi pour dire que c'est
y compris au sein de la gauche vous avez
parlé du pcf par exemple où certains
élus aussi sont pas d'accord les uns
avec les autres entre une conception
laïque traditionnel anticlérical
clairement et donc anti voile d'une
certaine manière mais sauf
qu'aujourd'hui c'est la droite qui la
pause 7 qui pose cette ppl c'est quand
même kazan en vrai vous avez raison
parce qu'un méchant
oui mais elle divise mais parce qu'elle
oblige elle oblige au débat mes mots
qu'on ait un débat sur cette question
mange pas de problème pour qu'on ait un
débat et je pense que c'est toujours
bien d'avoir des dégâts leur vous
ma position et je défends ma position
parce que je suis parce que je trouve
qu'on est en train d'amener les français
parce que ce sont des français malgré
tout et avant tout voilà on les amène
dans des débats qui ne sont pas et moi
je voudrais bien vous regardez regardez
en replay s'il vous plaît l'assemblée
nationale il me semble qu'il ya des
députés qui portent des grosse croix à
l'assemblée nationale on les a jamais
sorti les a jamais sortis de l'hémicycle
parce qu'ils avaient des grosses crois
et je les ai vus dans les plateaux télé
et je les ai vus partout alors dites-moi
si peut-être d'autres avaient mais non
mais ça ou sinon c'est à géométrie
variable cette histoire c'est un jeu
mais très variable par contre quand y
mène quand ils mènent des combats au nom
de l'église
oh non mais c'est leur droit à la limite
s'ils ont le droit s'ils sont croyants
que de penser qu' il faut pas là la paix
est mal gpa et ils ont le droit mais au
nom de quel droit ils le font si ce
n'est au nom d'une religion
non mais donc donc donc c'est libérer sa
série d'ambassades là ça devient le
débat là c'est le débat parce que c'est
porté par l'église catholique
exemple nation spécifiques sur des
musulmanes problème avec les musulmans
clamant je veux ça le problème avec lui
est un problème avec les musulmans
le cas et bien d'y un des premiers à
dire qu'on ne supporte plus en france le
monde politique
voilà je ne supporte plus les musulmans
ça c'est pas les musulmans qui ont un
problème c'est vraiment politique
aujourd'hui assure mais je pense que je
pense que aujourd'hui ça ça mène pas de
faire moi je trouve que c'est nul
parce que sincèrement avec la vrais
problèmes qu'on a dans nos biens
madame
[Musique]
benzia ten oui notamment l emploi dans
les collèges elle va dans les lycées
elle va avec quoi c'est là c'est la
maman de la maman de la première victime
de m'amène verra remettre berra qui est
également de du militaire ll aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui fait de la prévention et la
maigreur
c'est la plus grande allée près les
religieuses elle est allée collègues
elle et elle est voilée et porte et pour
autant
c'est la plus grande républicaine que je
connaisse parce qu'elle défend la
république française elle défend elle
défend finalement une forme de la
laïcité
elle défend justement il combat le
terrorisme
et cette dame là quand elle va dans les
lycées alors qu'elle est voilée la
personne qui lui dit qu'elle n'a pas le
droit
alors on va lui dire demain qu'elle ne
pourrait rien ne pourra plus y aller le
vernet à ce qui nous fait remarquer
qu'elle dit elle même que celle que le
voile est pour elle un signe de deuil
c'est vrai en plus à la raison c'est
vrai parce que souvent les femmes quand
elles perdent un enfant marie parent
proche
elle met d'abord j'aime pas ce terme de
voile vouloir parce que d'abord c'est
même pas le voile parce que le voile
c'est en général quelque chose qu'on met
devant et pas et pas sur la profondeur
sur le chemin qui est important parce
que même assez intéressante qu'elle est
la sémantique et piégeurs et piégés
mais vous avez parlé donc bon on vous
avait parlé du problème qu'on a
collectivement avec les musulmans qu en
tout cas la scène politique et peut-être
médiatique avec les musulmans
il ya aussi quelque chose en cette
rentrée qui s'est passé c'est que le
président de la république a décidé de
parler d'immigration
quand les tentes dans les pays arabes
nous verrons des églises et des
cathédrales se construire et non pas se
détruire mais moi je suis d'accord mais
moi je croyais encore je crois que c'est
pas il faut pas tout mélanger et je peux
vous dire que beaucoup de musulmans et
notamment
je les arabes de coptes avec qui j'étais
d'ailleurs encore dimanche et
j'étais avec le pape copte qui est venu
et qui se déplace très rarement sa
première fois qu'il venait en france
mais j'étais là parce que j'étais
justement en soutien et moins jeunes
justement je ne demande pas les uns
contre les autres je considère quand je
parle de liberté je suis sûr que je suis
honnête dans cette danse est un plagiat
justement ne jamais c'est que c'est pas
et c'est pas parce qu'on est musulman en
france qu on est d'accord avec le fait
qu'on puisse faire du mal à des gens qui
ne sont pas musulmans bien au contraire
les premiers d'ailleurs qu'ils vivent
qui souffrent du terrorisme sont souvent
les musulmans le même genre revient
quand même à ceux à ceux il ya quand
même le las a été donné en cette rentrée
par emmanuel macron qui a décidé de
mettre sur le devant de la scène
l'immigration il ya eu un débat au sénat
ça n'a rien à voir non ça n'a rien à
voir dans le fond dans le fond du débat
on sait qu'en france quand on parle
d'immigration très rapidement on parle
d'intégration et pour tout une partie
notamment de la droite assez rapidement
on parle de l'islam est ce qu'il n'ya
pas aussi un rôle joué par le
gouvernement là dedans non je crois que
franchement je crois que on peut
je crois qu'il ya deux choses on peut
parler de l'immigration et après et je
pense qu'il ya deux sujets la question
du foulard de la maman qui porte un
foulard pour qu'un accompagnant son
enfant à l'école je vois pas en quoi
celle là l'est en france elle vit en
france elle est française
ses impôts en france donc va de l'autre
côté on parle d'immigration mais
d'immigration ça n'a rien à voir c'est
deux choses différentes que l'on règle
la question d'immigration et qu'on se
dise qu'il ya un problème
oui d'immigration et qu'il faut qu'on
regarde de quelle façon puisse me régler
et que ça se passe en france mais aussi
dans les pays où l'immigration de
l'immigration vient mais moi je suis
complètement favorable ça